[Music]
hey everybody welcome back to Planet
Costa College in this episode I'll be
showing you how you can make spires and
domes because it's something that I've
done quite a lot especially in time
lapses recently but it's something which
I haven't really shown in detail how I
do it and I figured I would put them
both into one video because it's been
requested and they're kind of similar in
terms of how they're made so to start
with the easiest thing how do you make a
spire now I have a little tower over
here and you might be thinking well
that's a pretty good tower but it
definitely likes something on top of it
and basically what I want to have for
this tower is a spire which is any kind
of cone or pyramid shaped a very tall
roof on top of the tower and the way
that I make these is generally always
the same no matter what kind of shape
they come in the basic strategy for it
is to make one side of it and then copy
that side around to the others the
reason that I also make my own spires
instead of just taking the ingame ones
because there definitely are some
in-game spires as well is that sometimes
you just want to go for a very specific
shape for instance in this case as you
like the in-game spire is a little bit
too flat I want something a little bit
more tall but also in many cases for me
at least I'll have something a little
bit more unique something that you don't
see for any other players something that
specifically fits what I'm looking for
which is why I like making these things
myself so the basic idea is as such I'm
going to make one quarter of the spire
and then copy that side around to all of
the three other sides to make sure that
the entire spire is finished and to do
so I always place a wooden post in the
middle of the tower just so I have a
reference for the exact middle of the
building because since I'll be building
one quarter I definitely want to make
sure that I connect the ends of the
quarter to exactly in the middle so that
when I start copying these things around
all of the sides are going to connect
and form a perfect spire so the way that
I like to do this is first get an idea
of what I want despite it to look like
in this case I want something that's
very narrow and tall on top and flattens
out a little bit toward the side and I
got to get some kind of post
it doesn't really matter which one you
take but I want to have some kind of
post to outline what the look of the
spire is going to be like so in this
case I'm just going to drag this toward
the post over here to sort of create an
outline get an idea of what the spire is
going to be shaped like make that a
little bit bit higher there we go
something like that make sure that we're
connecting it to the middle and drag
that very long narrow part a little bit
more think in this case I might actually
yeah I might actually make this pie a
little bit smaller if I'm going to take
another piece to make the more flat side
here and that should more or less
basically be the entire outline of the
spire it might not look like anything at
this point but I'm going to lower it
down to just where I want it to be and
then I'm going to drag it over to the
other side to get an idea of what the
outline is going to be like now here's
something very crucial you want to
select the wooden post in the middle as
well which is a great object because if
you don't you're actually going to have
this word as very standalone draggable
object and that's something that we
don't actually want because we want this
to be exactly symmetrical so as soon as
I select the wooden post here what we're
going to copy/paste is actually going to
stay on the grid and this enables us to
actually place it perfectly on the other
side like that and get an idea of what
the spire would look like eventually and
now I can kind of see that I do want to
make the middle part a little bit larger
and actually make the spires taller as
well so here's what I want to change the
shape of my spire in general and this is
pretty important because once you get
the shape done and start making a spire
itself you can't really change the shape
that easily anymore so I definitely want
to make sure that I get the shape right
right here and if I copy that over again
I should get a pretty good idea of what
this thing is going to look like
eventually now I'm pretty happy with the
way this looks so it's time to fit on
the spire itself now what object you
using for that kind of depends on the
texture that you're looking for say for
instance I just want to have a very
simple wooden texture going over the top
you can just use these wooden planks and
throw it in that way but sometimes when
I'm feeling fancy I'll use the wooden
corbels to make custom shingles
and there are so many other very small
pieces for instance in the column
section as well some of the wooden
columns can be used to make a roof
texture as well
you can be very creative with this as
long as it's a small texture and you can
fill in the space between these wooden
beings without sticking out of the
wooden beams you can pretty much make a
spider out of it
now in this case I'm going to go with
the small pillar because it's just about
the texture that I'm looking for and
it's a somewhat easy way to throw in the
side of these roofs though it still is
pretty time-consuming basically what I
usually do is I align it with the side
of one of the beams here trying to make
sure to get the X X kind of rotation
done here and just as a test see if
that's correct
okay that's slightly off needs to rotate
its bit more to the right and see if
that's right okay a little bit more to
the left again and that should be just
about it so I'm going to give this thing
the color that I'm looking for and
basically go along the beams which I put
its guidelines earlier and this is very
very straight to the point just fill in
the space between these two beams and
it's it's a pretty annoying job it's
definitely pretty boring but that's
basically how I do it start filling it
up like that all the way to the top and
you basically have one quarter of a
custom spire now when you get closer to
the top you'll notice that it's going to
be very hard to fill in the very last
part of the spire as soon as you go up
too much the size of your beam I'm going
to stick out on the sides of the beams
that you had its guidelines so it's
still in the last part of the triangle
which is always the hardest part I
usually go to some of the small wooden
bracket or Korbel pieces to make sure
that I can fill it in with a very
similar texture but without having to
have everything stake out on the sides
it's definitely not the best way to save
on pulleys or frame rates but it's a
good way to keep going with a very
similar texture without having a very
open end of the spire and there we go
that's almost it now we just have to do
the lower part of the spire which is a
little bit annoying since it's pretty
much just the same as the other part of
the spire you also notice that making
spires is going to get
more and more complicated if you have
more more complicated kind of shapes so
if you're following different kinds of
curves with the general shape of the
tower you're going to have to follow
those every time with the beams that
you're placing in the middle so while
it's definitely possible to make onion
domes or much more complicated kind of
spires this way it definitely takes
quite a bit more effort and there you
have it
that's you aspire almost done there's
one last thing I would like to add to it
though because the spider doesn't have
any cornices as of now and that's
definitely something I want to add to
the spire to connect it to the rest of
the building make sure that it's not
just a floating part so I'm going to
drag this up a little bit because I do
too like it's a little bit too low now
let's see something just like that
should work and I'm going to place some
corners pieces right underneath it to
connect it to the rest of the building
one of these pieces should definitely
set the general look and style of the
timer that I'm going for and it connects
to the rest of the building as well
perfect just to add a little bit of
flair to that as well I do want to have
some of these wooden brackets now the
spire is pretty much almost done the
last thing that I want to do is remove
the beams which I had on this side to
make sure that I got the shape right and
select the entire spire
try not to include anything else which
can be kind of hard at times but we
basically want to get the entire spire
without anything else attached now once
we have everything all that's left to do
is to copy it around and place it on all
four sides and our spire should pretty
much be finished and there you have it
that's basically how to make a spire now
there's one last final touch that I
always like to add to these things and
which you can mess around with as well
and that is just something decorative on
top of the spire and now to get to the
exact middle of the spire I often place
a flat roof which allows us to get into
the exact middle of a tile with a
scenery object and then take some of the
Christmas decorations that we have in
scenery some of these Christmas baubles
which does sound very weird I know but I
love the way that these things actually
shape out your spire you can place these
on top of your spire and just give it
that slight touch of decoration maybe
this bar is a little bit large always
this kind of takes a bit of a messing
around
few actually works here it gives a bit
of a golden color there we go and one of
the larger bubbles underneath that to
support the entire thing and that is
pretty much a fancy tower decoration and
once we're ready with making this
decoration on top of the spire we can
remove everything and we have a fancy
spire so as for the second part of this
video which is about making domes I've
got a building over here which looks
alright but it definitely looks like it
could use a dome as well so I'll be
using it for that and showing you how to
do it because there's one very major
difference between domes and spires even
if they're built in a very similar way I
always use the grid when building spires
because they have the general square
shape and they're not that large
but since domes are very large and round
I usually only make one sliver of the
dome and then instead of using the grid
to copy that around and finish the dome
I use the 3d gizmo to rotate the part
and finish the dome that way so I'll
show you how it works first I want to
kind of measure the dimensions of the
building which I'm going to place the
dome on because I usually like to build
the dome outside of the building that
I'm going to be placing on just get a
better idea of what the dome looks like
and not have to mess too much with the
building itself and I think in this case
something like 2x2 maybe a little bit
larger it's going to work out just fine
so I'm going to take these things and
move them elsewhere and start building
my down there also I'm going to play
some wooden posts in the middle and
these are going to be very important
later on but for now they're really just
a guideline because I want to lay out a
very general idea of what the dome is
going to look like and for that I'm just
going to make an outline the dome using
some very small pieces that we can make
an outline with since in this case I'm
gonna kind of create a copper edge dome
I'm going to try to give it that sort of
color also you can make things a lot
easier by turning this post this way
basically what it will do is every time
you can just move it 115 degree
increments and again and again without
having to very precisely put all of
these things into the right position and
if I cook it over this part of the dome
to the other side I can get a very basic
idea of what it's going to look like
eventually and this is more or less what
I'm looking for so we're on the right
track now basically I want to have one
of these beams on eight sides of the
dome given the size obviously the larger
the dome is the more you want to have
like beams sticking out from the sides
and one pillar underneath each of these
but given this bike that this is pretty
small dome I would have about eight of
these and what this means is that I'm
going to have to throw in one-eighth of
the dome and then copy that one-eighth
around to make sure that I make the
entire dome and the way I usually do
this is like this I can actually get rid
of this pillar then I'm going to copy
this so that we have both sides of the
dome that we're looking for here and now
I'm going to take this actually copy
that without the pillar I can actually
remove one of the pillars in the middle
there copy that without the pillar and
once we press control X right now we can
actually duplicate that on the advanced
gizmo grid and if I turn on the angle
snaps took 45 degrees we can get it
exactly like this and basically this
also means that if I already start
duplicating it like so I already have
kind of the husk of the future dome
that's something that I'm not looking
for yet the only thing I want to do
right now is create one-eighth of the
dome and by doing this I've successfully
made one-eighth of the dome so I can
remove these sides again don't need
those anymore those we just to rotate
the pieces and now we can make the part
of the dome here copy this around and
we'll have the entire thing finished so
now I want to throw in the space between
these beams a very similar way to the
spire but it's a little bit more tough
here since there's obviously completely
different placements and we have a round
shape going on so what I usually do is
just a lot of trial and error I take the
pieces that I want to make my dome out
of in this case I'm actually clicking
among the pillar pieces over here since
they are quite wide and it should be
pretty usable and going to rotate this
take one of these very large pieces so
that we can actually get over to the
entire side and I'm going to try to get
the rotation perfectly in the middle of
the two points which we have over here
so here we can see it's sticking
in the pillar a little bit and basically
if I sneak it in there like that the
entire thing should be perfectly placed
between the dome and if I start moving
toward the center we're not going to
suddenly go completely offset from the
rest of the dome so that's perfect and
now I want to really start filling in
the dome itself so I'm going to go back
to the pillow that I wanted to use to
fill in the bits and basically just fill
in everything that we need to fill in
here same principle applies here very
long and boring placement of whatever
pieces you want to make your dome out of
obviously you can make your dome out of
a lot more pieces than just wood and
obviously the actual dome that I'm going
for is copper this is not a green copper
kind of dome texture and while this is
far from perfect for the sake of the
tutorial right now it's more or less
good than there are many different kinds
of objects that you can use for this
kind of texture sometimes it just takes
a bit of trial and error as well just
find out what textures work best as long
as you can use them to fill in the space
between the beams you should be good to
go again the top part is a little bit
tricky and in this case I'm using the
core Bowl since they have a very similar
texture to the beams that I'm using so
throw in the very top part which is
otherwise very narrow and that you can't
really fit any of these beams into and
there we go that's part of the dome this
is basically the base of the dome so
everything after this is just detailing
and further making the dome a little bit
nicer but I'll show you how it finishes
the entire thing in one go basically
again we select the entire thing
including the wooden post then we remove
the wooden post
select the entire thing without the
wooden post and once we start copying
stuff right now it's going to perfectly
connect and create an entire dome now
for the rest of this tutorial I'm just
going to have a lot of fun with
detailing so if you're interested in
that I guess you could say ground but
this is really the basics of making
domes and a lot of the rest it comes
down to experimenting with the details
but the first thing that I want to do to
make this thing a little bit more fancy
is to also add a Korean border around
the bottom where it's going to
transition into what's
the rest of the building because domes
are often built on top of a round part
with pillars or galleries something
fancy it's not just the dome on its own
so in this case I want to fill it up a
bit
with one of these slightly lighter kind
of wooden beams there we go that should
connected to the rest of the building
and then underneath that I'm going to
have a small wall piece now something to
remember here of course is that we're
not on the grid so any walls that we
want to make we can't actually make out
of actual wall pieces so it always takes
a bit of trial and error
to see what kind of pieces you can
actually make walls out of that aren't
actually conforming to the grid and in
this case especially these pillows in
staging they have a very similar texture
to what I used before are probably very
useful for what I'm trying to do here
yeah that more or less works let's place
these make a quick Bowl out of them and
that should be the first part of the
dome and on top of that I'm going to add
a very small corner Ridge having a very
similar color scheme to what we have for
the rest of this thing try to change it
a bit see what we have for the walls
something like that you more or less
work and that is the top part of the
dome and it's very simple fashion for
the rest of it I'm going to make it a
little bit wider so that's going to be
very interesting so I'm going to take
this piece and move it out a little bit
to create a corner piece like thing and
underneath that is a bit of decoration
as well make it a bit more interesting
and this is basically what the entire
dome is going to rest on as a kind of
pediment thing I'm going to be sure the
exact name for it would be but this is
also where the pillars are going to
stand underneath also I'm thinking this
balcony in just to give it a little bit
more detail and trying to use the back
as much as I can to add a little bit
underneath here there we go on us just
what I'm looking for using pieces like
this is definitely not great for a
computer but it can be a great way to
get some extra details that you can't
really get otherwise and now I'm going
to make the wall behind all of this so
again I'm putting a bunch of different
pillars together to make a wall sexier
it really depends on the kind of texture
or color that you're looking for which
of the pieces that you can use over here
but since in this case the color
actually matches quite well what I have
for the rest of the building I'm just
going to use these now I'm going to make
it very big since this is a pretty small
dome and that should more or less do it
it's quite quite a small sort of base
for the dome it should more or less do
actually going to put this through the
bottom over here you're not going to see
much of this given how low the dome is
going to stand on the building but that
should give a small wall on the bottom
of the dome and now the final thing that
I want to add are some pillars on the
sides where all of these beams are
coming together and I'll be using some
of the CMU pillows for this actually
since this is a very small building and
I don't think anything else will really
fit in there
so let's rotate this for a little bit
Xzibit bit sort this direction again
what's also very helpful about placing
pillars on all of these corners of domes
is that these domes are always
surrounded by pillars in real life so it
looks pretty good but also in the game
you're inevitably going to have that
some of these walls aren't quite going
to match up on the site when you copy
them and either there's some open space
between or they're going to clip into
each other a little bit this one's
definitely going to clip into another
one slightly and so what these pillows
will also allow you to do is to very
subtly kind of disguise any mistakes
that you made in the placement of the
walls or any places where they're just
going to bump into each other and just
put any little pillar over there also I
want to throw in this gap over here and
give it a very very slight little touch
on the bottom here that looks quite nice
and probably put a small window not sure
which one doesn't really matter anyway
but just make it look like it's an
actual building now I quickly deleted
one of those pieces I wasn't really a
big fan of them in the end and something
else that we are going to have to delete
at least the save on pieces or the
guidelines which we kept on the left
side here we don't really need any of
these fillers anymore so go ahead and
delete these and after that it's pretty
much time for the big moments we select
the entire thing copy it over to the
other side so we can rotate it delete
one of these posts up only one of them
and just rotate the entire thing and
it's not too shabby I think it can
definitely be improved especially on the
details but this is really just the
basic idea one thing that I would say
though is that you usually want to add a
cupola on top of your dome so entirely
necessary but it is super common and it
definitely makes them look a little bit
better so in this case I think I'll just
use one of the pre-made ones what I
often actually do is build my own dome
into place on top of the dome but I
don't want to go too meta here so I'm
just going to try and put one of these
towers on top of it to create a very
small simple cupola something like that
give it the same color and add some
detail to it and it should be fine
anyway that just about wraps it up for
this video
something to keep in mind though is that
you definitely shouldn't do this with
everything you build building these
spires and domes is something that I
really love doing and I do a lot but
it's because there are such prominent
features of a building like they're the
parts of the buildings that really stand
out and that you sometimes really want
to have something very unique for I
wouldn't really recommend doing this for
every single thing that you're building
but it's definitely a way to create some
of your own pieces that you don't really
have in the game yes the game has some
dome pieces the game has some spire
pieces but sometimes you want to have
something that looks just like exactly
what you're going for or something that
doesn't look like anything you've seen
before I think it's just a lot of fun to
try these things in there are a lot of
possible things that you can come up
with with this technique of using the
grid or the 3d gizmo to copy a part of a
building around to make an entire dome
or Aspire without having to make every
side separately so anyway I hope you
guys enjoyed this episode of planners
Costa College and I'll see you in the
next video